[Música]
[Aplausos]
en el 2016 decidí apoyar a el que hoy es
presidente emmanuel macrón porque era la
única persona que yo veía que podría
representar un camino diferente a la
división política que había en francia
él ha logrado componer con tantas
fuerzas políticas con la izquierda con
la derecha y que nosotros representamos
el centro pero realmente tenemos
responsables políticos de todas las
sensibilidades políticas yo lo viví en
venezuela la batalla entre entre dos
partidos digamos clásicos bipartismo
disfuncional que le hicieron y le están
haciendo mucho daño a la democracia
francesa
[Música]
y
el punto que es clave para mí es el
hecho de que promete salir de la
dependencia de los recursos geológicos
es decir el gas y el petróleo para la
producción de energía porque no es
posible que en el 2022 nosotros sigamos
dependiendo de líderes anti democráticos
[Música]
por ejemplo lo que está pasando en
ucrania ahorita presiento macro lo que
dijo es vamos a recibir a los migrantes
a los refugiados porque eso es lo que
son son perseguidos y como en venezuela
lo sabemos muy bien sabemos lo que lo
que es ser perseguidos y vivir en un
régimen en el cual no se tiene nada y
del cual se tiene que huir porque no se
puede vivir en ese país entonces el
presidente macro no quiere recibir de
manera responsable
[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo voy a votar más indepen porque y voy
a tomar la expresión de máximo porque la
franja es la compra que francia
permanezca francia porque es una cultura
una identidad que luce en todo el mundo
entonces si dejamos el oscurantismo
llegar a ese país será demasiado tarde
[Música]
ahí estamos para todos los franceses
para los nacionales y el de maco es muy
claro minutos
pues es como decir la división de un
pueblo
y una globalización total
y yo no quiero perder la identidad
[Música]
obviamente
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hay un dicho que dice en roma como las
romanas yo cuando voy a méxico me porto
como un mexicano hasta como más picoso
que los mexicanos y en ningún momento
les voy a decir que soy francés o que
soy franco mexicano a mí me gusta vivir
en el país
que me acoge como los ciudadanos de ese
mismo país y no entiendo que cuando
llegues a un país no quieras adoptar los
los hábitos de seguir
[Música]
[Aplausos]